Branagh par sur visuel d'accord mais j'ai perdu sa
trace Susan était là
nord-nord-est 113 degrés
croyez-moi directement dans un mur il a dit
qu'il voulait le chemin le plus court
[Musique]
faisons ça
regarde là
[Musique  ]
peut-être un chemin court mais ce n'est pas facile
[Musique]
valériane bienvenue dans alpha la ville des
mille planètes Alex peux-tu nous mettre à jour
Je serais ravi que la station Alpha
ait augmenté de sept pour cent cette année et
depuis qu'elle a dirigé l'orbite terrestre, elle
a  parcouru près de sept cents
millions de miles population près de 30
millions 3236 espèces des quatre
coins de l'univers vivent à bord
mettant en commun leurs connaissances et leur culture plus de
5000 langues parlées
sans compter les variantes de langages informatiques la
démographie au sud sont
les parties submergées avec 800 espèces
vivant dans  toutes sortes de liquides comme
les paisibles agriculteurs de Pollan qui cultivent du
cobalt au nord nous avons des
terres gazeuses dominées par la dépression de l'Adeem dont l'
extrême sensibilité en fait des
spécialistes  nd neurosciences et
composants moléculaires faisant de ces cellules
de toutes sortes à l'est l'essence de la
grande colonie sur les lumières
qu'elles contrôlent technologies de l'information
finance et banque enfin à l'ouest
dans une atmosphère sous pression nous avons 9
millions d'humains et d'espèces compatibles
home sweet home
let's go
[Musique]
quitter XO space trois deux un whoa
on est en retard
ouais mieux vaut tard que mort tu
veux conduire whoa remets ta main sur le
joystick laisse moi remettre tes mains sur
le joystick Allah s'il te plaît pour
ton coiffeur tu arrête de te
plaindre  ma conduite oui je suis désolé tu es un
bon conducteur tu es le meilleur conducteur
de tout toi oh merci
va te trouver
tu es le premier non non non non c'est pour
éviter une telle situation toutes nos
informations sont divisées de trois manières vers l'un de
nous et vous gardez des informations là où,
dommage, ce serait bien, vous allez
devoir donner  e moi le crédit va parce que je
n'ai pas grand chose sur moi oh combien fatigant si
le commandant était là il pourrait utiliser le
convertisseur pour nous payer mais il a été
enlevé surtout parce que l'
autre convertisseur ici sauf pour
des raisons de sécurité ou quelqu'un d'autre a été
transporté  sur qui a inspecté vous obtenez cette
information ce n'est pas intéressé l'action nous savons
comment les humains fonctionnent ils sont tous si
prévisibles
couperet vous n'avez jamais rencontré de femme
il y a longtemps quand j'avais 10 ans
j'ai découvert le premier album de cette
bande dessinée Elena  et j'étais comme oh mon
dieu qu'est-ce que cette chose que je pense était comme
moi est l'histoire racontant que c'était la première
fois que nous voyons le couple moderne, ils
agissaient comme deux personnes normales aujourd'hui
sauf qu'ils sont au 29ème siècle
et tout est  bizarre l'environnement
était juste fou
c'est comme des extraterrestres partout et des mondes
partout quand je travaillais sur le
cinquième élément avec le designer principal de mi-année
de Berlin, c'est lui qui disait pourquoi
ne fais pas vinayan pourquoi fais-tu cet
élément  chose que je veux dire, la technologie n'était
pas bonne à l'époque, ce n'était pas possible
et comme plus tard l'avatar est arrivé et l'
avatar rend tout possible, il
n'y a plus de limite mec je fais le sari
où elle est maintenant il y a 40 ans avez-vous
déjà pensé que vous obtiendriez  transformé en
film
non nous commençons à travailler avec l'artiste
trois ans avant au téléphone de
commencer le storyboard un an et demi
avant
nous étions si fiers quand au téléphone que
le tournage a presque l'air magnifique
et Laura lein il y a deux flics montrent
votre  pistolet quand vous faites du bon travail les garçons et
ils peuvent voyager dans l'espace et le temps la
valériane est peu prétentieuse à
compter j'ai pris un robot et si nous sommes
allés en renfort alors j'ai changé vous serez toujours
sauvera la situation tout est un
peu trop facile pour lui  le matin est
probablement mon premier amour dix ans tu
sais que tu commences à te sentir bien peut
faire beaucoup mieux
ravi de te revoir pas une
splendide entreprise moche
tu es très humain ce combat et tu es
désespérément amoureux de lui  r
[Musique]
J'ai utilisé une quête notre mère
leur mission les amener à travers la
station spatiale a rencontré au-dessus d'un millier d'
espèces extraterrestres des quatre coins de l'
univers
bienvenue à alpha alpha appelée la ville
des mille planètes parce que toute la
connaissance de l'univers est là  la
station Alpha compte 3236 espèces avec plus de
5000 langues parlées un wall street TG
de la science les Nations Unies ont
tout emporté là-dedans
donc ça fait de la ville la plus importante
de tout l'univers au paradis ça
a toujours été mon rêve avec les
personnages le grand écran  et maintenant c'est
le moment
sur le cinquième élément il y a 188
coups parfaits alors qu'en valériane il y a
2734 un peu mon modèle d'autonomisation pour faire
être fort et le voyage a été
incroyable je lui ai donné tout ce que j'avais
j'ai hâte de le partager avec vous alors  comme c'est
amusant
[Musique]
bienvenue dans notre ville aux mille
planètes après un siècle de paix et de
prospérité, une force inconnue a
détruit tout ce que nous avons créé
A  gence valériane et laura-leigh vous avez
moins de 10 heures pour trouver la menace
je suis éliminé
[Musique] l'
histoire est en marche
vous